In Ukraine tonight,
there are
new signs that a highly anticipated
offensive could get underway very soon.
Our chief international security
correspondent,
Nick Paton Walsh, is standing by
in the war zone in Ukraine for us.
Nick, tell us what you saw
during your visit
to the front lines today.
Yeah, Wolf.
To be clear,
Ukraine has yet to announce
his counteroffensive, indeed
has said that it may not,
in fact, do that
to ensure operational security.
But there have been a series
of unconfirmed
social media reports
suggesting two key occupied cities here
have had important
military and infrastructure
targets run by the Russians
meet vicious explosions and so,
again, that adds to a sense here
of a change in tempo.
Heightened anxiety and tension
that may be suggests
the prelude to this long
awaited counteroffensive
could be underway.
Here's what we saw ourself today.
Spring is
here after winter's frozen horror
and the buzz
and sting of Ukraine's
looming counteroffensive.
Is growing
aiming at Russian positions.
Within 30 seconds,
the Ukrainian unit has moved away
But it may be a precise operation,
but the Russian response is not
slamming
into the nearby town,
edging closer to us.
Impossible to tell
what the Russians are trying to hit.
But another example
of the intense bombardment
that bid
to stop the counteroffensive
from starting.
It is ordinary civilians
caught in the rising dust behind us
who bear the brunt of Russia's
frustrated rage
along and around the brutalized towns
where Ukraine says
it may launch its attack.
There are more signs
it is underway lurking in the foliage
than Ukraine has given, publicly said.
That's because Ukraine
has said nothing at all
about when, where or how it will attack
this month.
But among machine gunfire
in the nearby
trenches, a drone operators
hidden in the rubble.
The detailed, intimate picture
they have of their enemy
just two fields away is startling.
Watching and trying to kill each other
every hour.
They've noticed the Russians
pulling it back
Some were still searching
for Syrians
who came in from Syrian rebels.
This promises a new formula.
And you see
a tip or two concluded
by General McKiernan killed
short of the corner.
You know, the U.S.
Army shows that the professionalism
probably the drone
and you don't know where
do you draw scenarios here
and you're still no
on the Australian people.
The city was hit with
another drone team has seen the Russians
also left defending ruins,
ridden by chaos in their ranks.
Just just a little
disappointment in Australia with some
dudes on the subway.
It was
sort of possible to convert the neurotic,
most poignant strain
to the somewhat switches you can alluded
streakers on as well as some of that,
possibly even it.
It won't be long until that cunning
or chaos meets a decisive test
in this flat, open and perilous space.
Now, Wolf, it's pretty hard
to disassociate
the change in tempo
we've seen around here
with the idea
that a counter offensive
is not pretty imminent.
In fact,
the US have said
just in the last couple of days
that they've been helping train
the Ukrainians to make sure this is
a, quote, surprise attack.
But really, when it begins
is less important
than what it manages
to, in fact, achieve.
They need a strategic win here
to show Western backers
that the military weapons
they've been supplied
have been put to good use.
And to be sure, that support continues.
Given the economic electoral fluctuations
that could happen in the West
during this next summer,
really important for
Kiev to see some success.
Well, certainly is.
Nick Paton Walsh in the war zone for us.
Thank you.